drôle ce qui est historien et maître de
conférences à l'inalco institut national
des langues et civilisations orientales
bonjour bruno d'euros ce qui est merci
de répondre en direct à nos questions
sergueï lavrov a donc pris la parole il
concerne donc les accords de minsk selon
lui un seul point et respecter c'est
l'échangé des prisonniers en rappel un
cas eu un nouvel échange de prisonniers
le 16 avril dernier entre l'ukraine et
la république autoproclamée du du
donbass
ça a été saluée d'ailleurs par par
emmanuel macron on sait que c'est le
point 600d à des accords de minsk un
échange de prisonniers en revanche il
appelle au strict respect des accords de
minsk dans son dans son global et
notamment il appelle à un cessez le feu
c'est le premier point des accords de
minsk oui j'ai alors bien sûr tout ce
qui a été dit montre qu'on fait on
avance très peu puisque bien sûr que
l'échangé prisonniers c'est quelque
chose de positif mais tant qu'il n'y
aura pas de cessez le feu et de
négociations directes pour appliquer les
accords de mise que la situation restera
largement bloqué alors on peut
évidemment se poser la question qu'est
ce qu'ils planquent dans cette dans
cette situation et pourquoi le constat
semble fait par le ministre la france
qu'on n'a pas vraiment beaucoup avancé
en fait justement sergueï lavrov avait
dit la semaine dernière ils
s'attendaient à un peu d'avancé pour
cette réunion on sait que le dernier ce
mot fort mais au format normandie
d'ailleurs sergueï lavrov qui on termine
avec les questions des journalistes qui
vient de quitter
la table il l'avait dit la semaine
dernière il s'attendait à peu d'avancé
pour pour cette réunion comment est-ce
que ça se fait selon vous comment est ce
qu il a pu anticiper cela est ce que
toutes ces réunions qui s'accumulent au
final on n'a pas forcément d'avancé à
chaque fois où est-ce qu'on avance un
petit peu quand même
doit on avoir un petit peu dans la
mesure où il a pu avoir par exemple cet
échange de prisonniers mais enfin ça
c'était changement certes un peu
humanitaire mais qui ne règle pas le
fond du problème
s'il a déclaré avant que l'on n'allait
peut avancer c'est qu'évidemment les
canaux diplomatiques qui fonctionnent en
permanence lui permettait de se rendre
compte que la situation restait bloquée
quelles sont les causes évidemment de ce
blocage elles peuvent être différents
mais enfin ils sont quand même que la
situation globalement en ukraine est
bloqué pour toutes sortes de raison à
ceux qui ne sont pas forcément liées
uniquement nous confie du donbass mais
plus largement sur des questions
intérieures les rapports politiques
internes alors évidemment la dette les
tensions liées aux coronavirus n'êtes
pas la situation bien sûr mais c'est pas
la cause principale la cause principale
c'est sans doute le fait que l'état
ukrainien lui-même fonctionne mal
certains vont même jusqu'à dire qu'il ne
fonctionne pas du tout c'était exagéré
mais enfin il ne reste pas moins que
vous avez en ukraine
des milices qui sont plus ou moins
théoriquement soumise à l'armée mais qui
tend les fêtes mènent leur propre
politique et que donc dans cette
situation on peut supposer que le
président écrire un peu de marge de
manoeuvre à l'intérieur ce qui
évidemment l'amène à ne pas pouvoir
bouger beaucoup sur la question du temps
parce qu'ils modifieraient radicalement
la situation politique en ukraine parce
que admettant que d'une base réintègre
l'ukraine avec un statut spécial puisque
c'est l'objectif des accords de misc
automatiquement l'equilibre pour
l'éthique intérieur en ukraine serait
largement modifié c'est sans doute là
évidemment ou
blocage j'explique et sergueï lavrov
on l'a entendu concernant l'ukraine il a
il accuse kiev de refuser le dialogue
avec le donbass et est lougansk il a
dénoncé également des trafics d'armes et
on sait que bien les trafics d'armes
c'est le deuxième point des accords de
minsk le site le retrait des armes
lourdes de sa côte est de la ligne de
cessez-le-feu alors effectivement bourse
et trafic d'armes ils ont des causes
politiques et si je peux dire nationale
mais ils ont aussi des cons strictement
économique c'est à dire que beaucoup de
gens profitent du trafic d'armes
et justement dans un état vacillant ou
comme l'électro d'une ukraine
les groupes qui bénéficient de cette
situation de ni guerre ni paix ou semi
der hoeven base sont nombreux dont il ya
cet aspect des choses et pia s'est amusé
me lis plus ou moins dépendantes de
l'armée qui ont leur propre jeu et qui
se rendent bien compte que si la paix
est instaurée au donbass et que le
donbass quelque part rentrer dans le
crâne avec un statut spécial le rôle
politique diminuera et donc aussi
évidemment les avantages économiques
qu'ils en tirent donc tout cela est
évidemment mêlée et tant que la
situation en ukraine sera pas débloqué
faire tant qu'on n'aura pas un état
fonctionnant de façon plus du moins
équilibré et prévisible en ukraine on
peut évidemment s'attendre à ce que la
situation au donbass reste bloquée alors
maintenant effectivement les puissances
occidentales en particulier les deux qui
s'occupent du fond partie du format
normandie c'est à l'allemagne et la
france ont effectivement un rôle à jouer
et elles doivent pouvoir faire les
pressions nécessaires pour qu'on arrive
à la réalisation des accords de miesque
mais bien sûr
voir berlin et paris en ce moment
beaucoup d'autres soucis en tête et je
ne pense pas que l'ukraine cela leur
priorité
dans la situation actuelle justement la
situation actuelle on sait que c'est la
crise du coronavirus quels impacts de
cette crise sanitaire justement dans ce
conflit ukrainien alors il est clair que
l'état ukrainien est quand même assez
menacée par la crise du corner griffe
d'abord parce que le système sanitaire
en ukraine est encore très très précaire
dans son fonctionnement et puis vous
avez une masse d'ukrainiens les
travailleurs écrire qui travaillait dans
beaucoup de pays de l'union européenne
qui ont été amenés à rentrer au pays en
catastrophe au moment de la fermeture
des frontières et de la délivrance iman
massifs qui ont visé ces immigrés dont
vous avez évidemment une masse
d'ukrainiens qui se sont retrouvés en
frontières de leur pays ou qui sont même
rentrés dans leur pays et qui sont
évidemment le souci dominant des
autorités ukrainiennes aujourd'hui c'est
comment faire en sorte que cette masse
de gens rentrent au pays sans que le
virus ne se répande et puis le deuxième
aspect des choses c'est l'aspect
financier c'est que tous ces immigrés
qui rentre c'est autant d'argent qui ne
sera plus injecter dans le circuit
financier ukrainien puisqu'il ne gagne
plus d'argent à l'étranger donc même les
autorités de kiev ont des soucis
beaucoup plus importants à régler
aujourd'hui que le conflit qui donne pas
ce qu'il veut expliquer aussi les
retards pendant ce qui j'en propose de
réécouter un une partie de la conférence
de presse de sergueï lavrov le chef de
la diplomatie russe qui appelle à un
cessez le feu dans la région de tamba
suis avions encore une fois à la station
pop le 7 juillet
les statistiques ont montré des
statistiques sur place et sa mission sur
place et ses nombreux les bombardements
de localiser des trucs opposition suivre
sa mort pour le double cette matière de
ces localités situées monsieur votre sur
le terrain insiste que vous allez dans
l'autre sens lille c'est vrai que je
suis sa liste il rappelé look f ou nixon
a donné mes mesures supplémentaires pour
que leur baisse frais ça tu sais c'est
que je sois je m'assure et voilà donc un
sergueï lavrov qui appelle à un cessez
le feu et qui salue les échanges de
prisonniers
le dernier en date le 16 avril on sait
qu'il devait y avoir s'il n'y avait pas
eu cette crise du coronavirus un nouveau
sommet de visu physique une au sommet au
format normandie c'est à dire entre
vladimir poutine vladimir poutine
volodymyr zelensky emmanuel macron et
angela merkel la dernière fois c'était à
paris le 9 décembre dernier
à quoi faut-il s'attendre après
les mollahs de sergueï lavrov dans les
semaines dans les mois à venir ce qui va
y avoir un nouveau rendez vous entre ces
quatre chefs d'état
évidemment il ya la crise du cours d'un
virus peut être par visioconférence ou
ou peut-être de visu si cette crise du
cours navire le seul s'arrête il est sûr
que c'est beaucoup toujours beaucoup
mieux quand quand une conférence a lieu
deux vigiles parce que cet aspect
psychologique joue très importante de
façon très important dans les
négociations diplomatiques toujours le
contact direct ne peut pas être remplacé
par un contact vision conférence ont
fait on fait de la vie dure aux
visioconférences faute de mieux mais ça
n'est évidemment pas l'idéal
alors à quoi s'attendre
comme je voulais 10 c'est tout dépendra
de la capacité du gouvernement ukrainien
à maîtriser la situation dans son pays y
compris sur le plan du coronavirus et je
ne je ne suis pas persuadé que l'absence
de cessez-le-feu soit dû à une volonté
de kiev au sens où se gérer une volonté
du président ukrainien ou même du
gouvernement ukrainien d'entretenir les
tensions mais je pense que c'est pas
tout simplement le manque de contrôle de
la situation sur le front par les
autorités de kiev et le rôle disons tout
à fait autonome pour ne pas parler pour
ne pas dire plus
d des forces militaires qui sont sur
place qui ont elles intérêt à maintenir
un climat de tension pour des raisons à
la fois de business commerciale et pour
des raisons de de pression politique
justement sur kiev je pense qu'on fait
je me le fief attendu l'actuel ou là
vraiment ukrainiens sont de plus de
problèmes avec ses propres troupes
qu'avec les républiques du d'audace
merci pour ce qui est d'avoir répondu à
nos questions et d'avoir à débriefer
donc cette conférence de presse de
sergueï lavrov après cette réunion en
format normandie par visio conférence
merci pour nous dire ce qui je rappelle
que vous êtes donc historien et maître
de conférences à l'inalco